Speaker 1: It is the one year anniversary of the
January 6th Trump riots. We are going to have a
little bit of coverage of that later today. We're
also going to carry on tomorrow's show. We'll have
some clips from Joe Biden's statement, his speech
today about that one year anniversary. Very,
very heavily placing a lot of the blame on Donald
Trump did Joe Biden today. But we'll talk about
that later and tomorrow. There is so much else
to get to, and I'm going to jump right into it.
As many of you know, any opportunity that I
have to clear up confusion or misinformation,
disinformation, propaganda or bad math and
statistics. Those are opportunities that I relish.
And unfortunately, the opportunity we have
today is to look at a clip from Republican
Senator Rand Paul, who to some people very
convincingly made an argument yesterday
not only against vaccine mandates but against
vaccines at all when it comes to coronavirus.
And so we're going to look at this clip. There's a
bunch of different concepts here that are relevant
and that are important, so I'm going to be making
notes of each of the aspects of what he says that
need to be discussed. See if you can pick out
the fallacious claims and then we're going to
talk about it in more detail. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: And so what we're dealing with is now a
different disease and it needs to be treated
differently and we need to get rid of the
hysteria. But the people who are promoting this
stereo work for the government, I mean, this is
Dr. Fauci's fault, largely worse because
he's still hysterically talking about
mandates and shutting people down and not
letting people fly and blaming the unvaccinated.
Everybody's getting this vaccinated
unvaccinated. In fact, the majority
of the people in the hospital now are vaccinated
because almost everybody has been vaccinated.
Speaker 1: Now that is a lot of disinformation.
But there's one really funny thing at the end
of what Rand Paul says he actually
gets to something that's really
important in understanding the effectiveness
and efficacy of vaccines, which is, he says,
because almost everyone is vaccinated now. That's
not actually true in the United States. We have a
pathetically embarrassingly low vaccination
rate relative to so many other countries,
specifically because of Republicans and Trump
supporters who have one of the lowest vaccination
rates in any country that has widespread access to
vaccines. You can look at countries that don't yet
have widespread access to vaccines as they well,
they have lower rates than Republicans. Yes, but
they have no access to vaccines among groups. If
you look at, you know, Spanish right wingers and
you know, whatever group you want, American
Republicans are arguably and I think probably,
undoubtedly, although right up there the least
vaccinated group among any group in countries
with widespread vaccine access and by far the
most unvaccinated group in the United States. But
Rand Paul gets to something really important.
In a country where everyone is vaccinated.
Everybody with COVID would be vaccinated. That
doesn't really tell you anything about how good
the vaccines are at preventing illness at all,
preventing symptomatic illness, preventing serious
illness, hospitalization or death. I mean, think
about that. No vaccine is 100 percent. And thus
the more vaccinated a country is the higher number
of people who are vaccinated that are going to get
that disease. It doesn't actually tell you how
much better off you are being vaccinated than not.
If you get to 100 percent vaccinated, every case
will be in a vaccinated person. What we need to be
looking at are the outcomes and the relative risk.
Imagine a country with 99 percent vaccination
and 90 percent of the hospitalizations are in that
one percent that's not vaccinated. Even though
you you have this high level of vaccination,
you would still say you're way better off
vaccinated than unvaccinated. So let's look at
some data along those lines. When we look at,
we can look at a bunch of different places.
Let's start with Kentucky. You look at
hospitalizations in Kentucky as of yesterday.
OK. Forty five inpatient hospitalizations.
76 percent were unvaccinated, whereas 24 percent
were vaccinated, even though the majority
of Kentucky residents are vaccinated.
Three quarters of those in the hospital
did not have the vaccine. The relative
risk of being unvaccinated is significant.
OK, you look at critical care and ICU patients, 11
of them. 100 percent of them are unvaccinated. So
even though Rand Paul might look and say
most people are vaccinated and the numbers
are going crazy, look at the 11 people in
an ICU. I think this is admitted yesterday,
100 percent of them are unvaccinated. And if you
look at the six patients that are on ventilators,
none of those people are vaccinated. This is what
we're hearing anecdotally from emergency room
doctors. The people with three vaccines are having
very mild illness and don't need to be in the
hospital. Generally speaking, there's obviously
exceptions to everything. Let's look next at Whoa,
that's a picture of me. Don't know where that
came from. Let's look at Ontario. In Ontario,
you have three charts here. I'll describe them
for people that are not that are not watching
that are just listening today. If you look at
cases, cases are going up among everybody now.
These these are per capita. So this is important
to understand this is per capita the leftmost
graph COVID cases. You see that the rate
among the unvaccinated is significantly higher
than among those with at least two doses. It's
going up for everybody because Macron is so
contagious. Now look at who's in the hospital.
The gap between unvaccinated and vaccinated in
the hospital is incredible in Ontario among the
unvaccinated. The hospitalization rate is about
550 per million inhabitants, whereas the rate
among the vaccinated is only about 100. You have a
five and a half times higher rate of being
in the hospital. If you're unvaccinated
and then if you look at ICU, the numbers are even
more stunning. ICU occupancy among unvaccinated
people is about 140 per million. It's only about
10 for those who are vaccinated, so that puts you
14 times higher risk of ending up in
the ICU if you are not vaccinated. Last
illustration here is from New York City looking at
New York City. Here you see, this is just cases.
Cases are going up for everybody, but the purple
line is cases per 100000. Among the unvaccinated,
it's about 5500 per 100000 cases. Among the
vaccinated are about 300. OK, 15 x or so
higher. So Rand Paul is mathematically correct in
that increasingly, as more people get vaccinated,
more and more of the cases will be among
the vaccinated. That's just simple math.
Its base rates, but the rate of hospitalization,
intubation and death continues to be
dramatically higher among those who have
not been vaccinated. This is why this is
around the world. There is no country in which
this is not being observed. So very dangerous
disinformation from Rand Paul, which a lot
of these Fox News viewers sycophant types
grasp on to for dear life and uncritically
repeat. Understand the math very, very important.